es seien etwa vierten teil der
eignungsprüfung den kind im stecker und
die bildung der gegenstück zu den
liegestützen bei dieser übung wenn ihr
zu den beats
das heißt den hamburger und die große
rückenmuskulatur für mich als biathlet
ist es eine wichtige übung und bat um
eine sprengung ich zeige jetzt was dich
erwartet
für die kinder im shaker gibt es bei der
eignungsprüfung ein eigener sport
prüfgerät gehen die ausgangsposition
setzt sich im lang sitzt unter die
stange nun greifen die stange mit den
händen
beim hochziehen ist wichtig dass du
nicht mit der hüfte schwung horst
sondern sich quasi aus dem ärmel
hochtief mit dem hals ziehen
sonst riskiert zu verspannungen und
muskelzerrungen und immer auf die
hochspannung aufpassen und nicht
durchhängen bei der eignungsprüfung
zählt der klinik nur wenn die stange die
post gehört und dann wieder in die
ausgangsposition mit gestreckten armen
gest bei der übung ist auch der politik
wenn du die klimmzüge zu langsam macht
ist es wesentlich anstrengender
vergiss nicht während der belastung beim
hochdrehen auszuatmen abschließender
tipp von mir die kinder game steigern
konnte reichen weit in ihren bereichen
geländer tischkante wie es die gegner
dazu trainiert nur so weit wie bisher